buenos días keiko fujimori y sus
abogados han presentado acciones de
nulidad a 200 minutos si el jurado
nacional de elecciones les da la razón
quizás la tendencia podría revertirse
pero esto va a ser algo complicado
porque para diversos observadores
internacionales como la organización de
los estados americanos los comicios en
perú han transcurrido con normalidad y
no ha habido ningún fraude como afirman
la lideresa fujimorista en todo caso la
espectativa se mantiene latente porque
en perú cualquier cosa puede suceder
respecto a keiko fujimori ella va a
continuar con sus actividades con toda
normalidad ella ha rechazado el pedido
de previsión para vendida de la fiscalía
y ha afirmado que todo se debe la
reacción de la fiscalía se debe a que
ella ha pedido la nulidad de 200.000
votos ahora francisco que reacciones hay
por las felicitaciones extranjeras que
ya se han dado a pedro castillo cuando
aún la onpe no ha dado un ganador
oficial
el gobierno peruano ha presentado una
nota de protesta a la argentina porque
su presidente el mandatario argentino
alberto fernández ha felicitado a pedro
que ha sido como presidente electo de
los peruanos para la cancillería peruana
el gesto del presidente fernández es
algo indebido porque según señala la
cancillería el conteo final de votos
todavía no ha sido anunciado en su
totalidad no ha sido oficialmente
establecido quién es el vencedor por las
autoridades peruanas francisco gracias
por la información estamos muy
pendientes a lo que ocurre entonces en
el perú